we are delighted to have in our studios
Margaret she's Hong Kong's leading
politician barrister writer columnist
she has been an integral part of Hong
Kong's life for the last four decades
Margaret welcome Margaret the Hong Kong
Occupy movement which was called the
umbrella movement has caught the
attention of the world the something is
going on in Hong Kong that requires or
that kind of inspires hundreds of
thousands of people to come to the
street now for our audience if you could
give us a little sort of maybe forted
history as to how we came to this point
when it's 79 days Occupy movement the
world's longest Occupy movement took
place in Hong Kong it is really very
very astonishing that it lasted nearly
80 days another astonishing thing is
that it's mainly moved by the young
generation the generation who said said
how is my future
I should be master of my own fate I have
waited long enough for this
democratization process to happen in
Hong Kong let us see real democracy we
don't want the Beijing package that is
distress so bring us through this what
is the Democratic package that people
are asking for and what was the original
deal when in 1997 Hong Kong was
sovereignty us transferred by the
British to China a Chinese did promise
something and so tell us what what
happened it really goes back 30 years to
1984 when Britain and China signed that
joint declaration on the one hand
Britain will hand Hong Kong back to
China on the other hand China said that
after they resumed the exercise of
sovereignty they would practice
12-point policy on Hong Kong and
basically Hong Kong systems will remain
unchanged the legal system the way of
life protection of rights and so on it
will have its own executive power his
own legislature so but the basic thing
is to preserve the existing Hong Kong
system 7 except that it would be under
Chinese sovereignty yeah I think the
wording was that accepting defense and
Foreign Affairs exactly Hong Kong would
be granted a high degree of autonomy
absolutely the high degree of autonomy
was really necessary because China runs
under a socialist system they are a
socialist state they are run by the
Chinese Communist Party Hong Kong was a
colony but Hong Kong had the rule of law
and Hong Kong had an open sort of life
and so some sort of installation if you
want to keep Hong Kong system then
you've got to put Hong Kong people in
charge it's really as simple as that so
the joint declaration 1984 yes and then
the basic law was drafted in in 1999 yes
the part of the joint declaration was
okay China has this 12-point policy how
is it going to be guaranteed of course a
joint declaration itself was an
international treaty and he was rejected
China between Britain and China and it
was registered in the UN and the world
has the right to monitor how it happened
how it was going to be implemented but
part of the joint declaration was his 12
point policy was not merely an
expression of a wish China also said
that this is going to be enshrined in a
basic law under the Chinese Constitution
so it has a very special position in
Hong Kong it guarantees it is legal
basis its powers and its autonomy so
what happened was in terms of in
practical terms yes let's go Legislative
Council yes was consisting of of elected
people
for functional groups yes ultimately it
was very unsatisfactory at the point of
transition because less than half of the
legislative body was elected by real
election direct geographical elections
we have half of the legislature elected
by what is known as functional
constituencies basically a privileged
position of business interest vested
interest professional groups and so on
so on the one hand the real elections
less than half of the council had were
elected by more than 3 million the other
half was elected by something like
250,000 voters and many of them were not
human being so it was it was it was a
very lopsided very lopsided but we were
hoping and it was promised in the basic
law that gradually it would become more
and more democratic until ultimately
every member every seat would be
returned by direct geographical election
universal suffrage universal suffrage
and also of course the election of a
chief executive so so from 1997 the
let's go indirectly actions and then
they yes elected and the chief executing
is who was essentially a Beijing
candidate but formalized yes to use the
word formalized you know because
everyone knows that that person is
handpicked by by Beijing and then he
goes through a kind of so-called
election process but the people who
elected him actually come from the
functional constituencies and they form
into an election committee of 800 and
then progressed to 1,000 and 200 but
basically they were the same basis and
they elected the person that Beijing
wants to elect yeah and so that thing
has continued and then Beijing promised
some reform yes
and they reform that the promise was
announced in August last year that's
right yeah tell us what happened is the
last straw I think that people have been
very very patient they understand that
this is going to be a gradual process
but several years ago measuring promised
that in 2017 the chief executive could
be could be elected by universal
suffrage so everyone was waiting to see
what happens what was as the model
supposed to be for 2017 and the model
turns out to be in effect Beijing will
choose the candidates two or three of
them and then Hong Kong people would
vote on these candidates so this is not
really allowing people to choose their
candidates of universal suffrage means
two things everybody votes every other
person votes and every other person has
a right to contest election yes you are
free to stand for election and you are
free to elect the candidate of your
choice that's the basis the Chinese
definitional universal suffrage is that
you vote what I choose the candidate yes
well there are still people who feel
that well even so it is not so bad
because even if you have only two or
three candidates and even if all of them
are accepted by Beijing the race the
election campaign they contest in the
election if there's a real contest there
would still be a democratization process
but I don't think anything of the sort
because if Beijing gets to pick the
candidates measuring would avoid any
kind of real election real contest
because the one basis on which Beijing
can give you a kind of one-person
one-vote is that if they can predict if
they can identify who is going to be
elected from the very start the last
election committee meeting didn't turn
out well although both of the real
candidates were Pro Beijing because when
you have the pro Beijing
actions fighting each other in fact it
was more damaging to Beijing but anyhow
so the point is yes when the Chinese
government announced this so-called
reform then the students said they would
accept it basically I think that
everybody was very shocked and they fell
many people who have been waiting
patiently became very very disillusioned
and they feel that this is really going
too far there is actually no opening and
no chance for it to develop because
Beijing says this is universal suffrage
take it or leave it
and so Hong Kong people were looking for
a way of expressing that dissatisfaction
but the students became the leaders in
expressing this dissatisfaction they
started with a very mild peaceful class
boycott they set in the park near
government quarters they held classes
there and so on but the sit-in was
suddenly shattered because of the strong
hand the harsh way they were dealt with
the police stopped people from joining
the rally then teargas were released and
so that really exploded the umbrella
movement really exploded and so people
who are somewhat indifferent they were
energized by the police action yes they
were Hong Kong people very mild but when
the government overreacts and then when
very unreasonable actions were taken
they get very angry and they rushed to
the site to support the students that's
why from a few thousand they became tens
of thousands of people and they decided
to occupy the very central parts of the
city and so they occupied and tell us
about how this occupation could continue
for so long how do what did they about
food about water it was really very
amazing it was I would say that it
happened
almost by accident because of them for
two years that there were people were
thinking of a movement called occupy
central with love and peace so it was
going to be a very peaceful civil
disobedience movement they were all
going to sit in the banking area waiting
to be arrested but that didn't happen it
happened in a totally different way when
the police fired tear gas into the crowd
and they were forced to stay on the site
then that was a totally different
situation that becomes a different kind
of occupy now when people were there and
they had to stay there then you have
people going there with food with
donations of water of medical care you
have tents set up to look after the
people who were occupying the place and
so on so as to continue with this a
peaceful demonstration it was a very
bizarre sort of situation so it was in
some ways there it was a mini city with
a municipal government because people
are bringing in food there is a medical
station set up first people didn't
expect that it would be it would be
prolonged in this way so they were they
were just sleeping on the ground and
they some of them would have to go away
during the day but as they stayed on
then they start to have to have
longer-term things they have to set up
tents then they the students there don't
want to leave the homework behind so you
have to have areas for the students to
study and because people were staying
there for on a long term the whole day
basis they needed food they needed water
they needed to be taken care of and
because there were alarms of police
crackdown from time to time so there has
to be medical centres in case anyone is
unwell to be taken care of and so on so
in the beginning there was attention of
police crackdown happening anytime but
as the situation just sort of become
very uncertain
and people just stay there and they
didn't know when it was going to end and
so they become a kind of self educating
self-governing community and that was
what lasts there seems to have been a
period when the government was really
getting ready to crackdown in the
beginning yes and then they changed that
tactic it was very strange because you
know here were the the anti squad for
anti riot squad which was a very serious
matter and they were prepared to with
banners to say disperse or we shoot you
know so everybody had memories of
Tiananmen and everybody was very very
anxious and then secondly action was
caught off you know people were warning
the students to go away because you must
value your life you must save yourself
don't stay here it is dangerous and this
went on for a couple of days and then
after action was caught off just we
don't know what happened next but
students seem to be kept there on the
site so so one can surmise that
authorities in Beijing saw that to have
even a mini Tiananmen situation in Hong
Kong was damaging for a financial centre
of course imagine having the kind of
Tiananmen scene happening in the central
of Hong Kong when it happened in Beijing
the Foreign Press cannot monitor it they
were they were they they have to go away
they were shooed away but Hong Kong is a
very open city and just as China was
trying to tell the world we are a strong
economic power and we want to take our
place in the world stage they don't want
a kind of mini Tiananmen happening in in
Hong Kong and I think that that was was
it was perfectly possible that it was
Beijing which caught off the action and
and perhaps the calculated that the
disruption of life if it continued for a
long time the support for the movement
would dwindle and that's what happened
yes part of the suit they change tech
they think that if they would let things
drag on this occupy were inconvenience
people people would get very irritated
and support for the occupiers the
protesters will turn into opposition and
the protesters will go away and and in
any event when they finally clear the
site there was very little opposition
but at the same time was very
interesting is that those 79 days
actually helped a kind of bonding of
these very special group of people they
they they were they were talking to each
other all the time and the overwhelming
topic was what is our future
how can we make Hong Kong work if we
allow this government to run on
according to the present lines we're not
going to get anywhere so so this 79 days
actually served as a kind of intense
education for the students yes because
they were trying to understand all the
legal niceties and actually you also
played a role in after giving some
seminars supporting members of public
were there they were they were they were
determined to occupy the place and not
go away but what they were doing there
was also discussing in a both
theoretical and and a practical sort of
way
solutions for Hong Kong's future so
people like us were invited to give
talks to them on democracy on the rule
of law on community building on all
sorts of things and they were listening
to all these talks very eagerly they
asked very good questions so there was
it was almost a crash course in
democracy and the rule of law and I
think that if there was one message
which got to them and I want to
emphasize that this group of protesters
were very different there is a
generational change as well as a change
of positioning in my generation we think
that the thing is to voice what we
consider to be our rights and our wishes
and those the powers-that-be should see
to it that our wishes are carried out
but the new generation of protesters
take possession of the issue they say
this is our responsibility so our task
is to find out how we can do it and so
educating people like this is a great
pleasure so I think they will change
Hong Kong so so the education was not
only for the students but actually the
world got educated about Chinese way of
dealing with international law because
when British parliamentarians were
planning to come to Hong Kong yes the
Chinese government said you are not
welcome and announced that the joint
declaration is now void yes tell us what
does it mean this voiding of
international to my generation I mean to
the people in the India umbrella square
they were mostly concerned with their
own future in their City
what is Hong Kong's future going to be
and they were trying to work that out
for the older generation like us because
we know how Hong Kong got to the place
that it is now and the basis is a joint
declaration and the basic law so this
the umbrella movement sparked off a
debate in the House of Commons in
Britain they say well how has the
government been monitoring the
implementation of the joint declaration
why is the umbrella movement happening
and so there was a debate in the House
of Commons and it was in the debate that
suddenly they were told that they have
no standing Britain had no standing to
monitor what's happening in Hong Kong
because the john joint declaration is
now void then the boy meaning what said
that yes hong kong would maintain its
style of life yes for 50 years in other
words until 20 47 that's correct the
agreement would hold and Britain in
naturally would have a say in
don't put it very very bad in a very
simple terms Hong Kong was returned it
was returned to China on the promise of
China would give Hong Kong a high degree
of autonomy
now Hong Kong has been returned to China
and are you telling me that the second
part is now void I mean that doesn't
make sense so I think this is important
not only for Hong Kong Hong Kong will
find its way forward and we want to
build our future on the promise of the
basic law and if this is not going on
then people have to ask how will they
how would they safeguard their future
but for the world there is a greater
significance
how can an international bilateral
treaty be unilaterally declared to be
void by one of the signing parties yeah
and what does it tell about the
reliability of China as it partners when
you think about the rule of law you know
then this is a country refuses to be
bound by the very treaty that it has
signed and now it says that it only the
returning Hong Kong to China part is
bilateral the other part is unilateral
then you have to think about China again
you have to look at China in a new light
what kind of an international player it
is but I think the more practical part
of it is this that is the people the
whole world cared about the joint
declaration 30 years ago because so many
international community members of
community was trading in Hong Kong they
were living in Hong Kong they were doing
business in Hong Kong the international
press was in Hong Kong if you want to
learn anything about China Hong Kong is
the best place now are you going to
change all that are you going to say
that none of this will be maintained and
if so how is the world going to do
business in Hong Kong with China or with
each other there are some people who
think that because China is now
economically successful Hong Kong is now
dispensable I do
think that this is the case at all and
if you ask people who do business in
Hong Kong it is because they rely on the
legal system they rely on the rule of
law they know that their rights are
protected by law they know that there is
freedom of information and if that is
why when the freedom of the press is
affected people sit up and say they get
really concerned so I don't think that
it is a matter of just for Hong Kong
people because they want democracy
because they want to have a control over
their own city which i think is all very
legitimate but also because what is Hong
Kong going to become if Hong Kong cannot
run its own systems
so all this looks a bit depressing but
from what I gather is that the students
are not depressed although the movement
has ended yeah I am not depressed I have
to say that although it is it is you're
right that it is depressing to see this
there's so much pressure and there's so
much the China is being so very stubborn
and so difficult to communicate refuses
to communicate that its priorities are
so very different from Hong Kong's
priorities and matters are urgent and we
find it very difficult to move forward
all these are very depressing but I'm
not depressed in for two reasons one is
that the world is noticing Hong Kong
again they start to us again is the
joint declaration spent do we now still
need the guarantee that China is going
to honor its promise an international
concern is extremely important secondly
the second date the new generation has
brought a new energy they are no longer
prepared to sit there and wait for
democracy to come to them they are no
longer content for someone else to look
after the rule of law they are prepared
to give their energy into the future of
Hong Kong to protect these systems and I
think this is wonderful you know if you
don't if you don't struggle for your
future you have no hope
democracy will never be given to you on
a plate
and the rule of law will not be
maintained
just at because they did the government
thinks that it is a good thing you've
got to protect it all the time eternal
vigilance and they've learned how
important it is they've gone through the
umbrella movement I don't think that
they are going to be the same people
again so we have a very energetic and
very very well I think they have very
mature minds and they have been sort of
transformed by this experience they have
been utterly transformed by the
experience and there is a new bonding
there and I don't think anybody can take
that away mm-hmm
well on that hopeful note thank you very
much my girl thank you for coming to a
studio thank you